[Music]
the cuddly morris and the powerful great
protector are just two of the incredible
creatures who play a big role in marvel
studios shanxi and the legend of the ten
rings to learn more about how they were
brought to life i'm speaking with vfx
supervisor christopher townsend hey
chris hey how you doing
this film brings so many new creatures
into the marvel cinematic universe how
did you work with the visual development
team to envision these characters and
then actually bring them to life with
vfx
so working with the vis-dev department
at marvel they would start creating some
of the characters the creatures the
looks the environments of sort of
general guidelines of this is where we
want you to go
we take that initial artwork and then
start developing it into a grounded
realistic looking creature
that's quite a different challenge and
that's i think where visual effects
comes in which is so exciting
so then how do you take a fantastical
creature like morris or the great
protector and make them feel as real as
the other characters on screen i think
it's very easy to design something as a
cgi character that is otherworldly but
it's very difficult to relate to it and
to therefore believe it so you always
have to try and find things that you can
grab hold of as an audience because you
never want the audience to sort of step
outside of the film you always want them
to be sort of fully engaged
well i know that morris stole my heart
how did you work with the team to create
his overall look and characterization
morris was a very interesting character
to work with his sort of
characterization is that he is a
faceless six-legged winged furry
creature so yeah trying to find a way
for that character to emote and look
cute and friendly without a face has
been incredibly challenging we obviously
looked at different animals
out there in the real world is he like a
bear the way he walks or is he like a
dog on tiptoes is he like a horse when
he trots or you know what does a
skeleton look like and so there were an
awful lot of animation tests that we did
early on to try and figure out the
mechanics of how he moved the other
thing you have to really consider is how
the feathers work and the wings and so
we're looking at ostriches and other
strange looking creatures trying to
really figure out not only the
ergonomics and the mechanics but the
physiology and the aesthetic to try and
make it feel as real as possible
so when morris is in a scene with
another character what are the actors
using as reference so during filming
obviously one of the key things is
trying to explain to the actors exactly
what it is they would be looking at the
way it was manifested on set was a big
green cushion that the actors had to
lift up and hold and stroke and prod we
had morris on a stick we were able to
sort of puppeteer him across the floor
to act as an eye line
so once you get that footage from set
how do you go about actually bringing
morris to life the first thing is
tracking it in relation to the camera
and in relation to the world and in
relation to the actor you can then start
replacing the cushion with a cg
character that you've created the big
challenge then is the interaction and
obviously with morris particularly he's
got fur and he's got feathers and so we
would have our actors be touching the
green form and then we would replace
that green form with our furry character
and then it's a matter of lighting it
and rendering it so that it looks
exactly like the lighting on the actors
and the set pieces around them and it's
a very very careful process of
compositing that character into the
scene correctly within the set and under
the fingers of all that kind of stuff
and it takes many many weeks months to
do an individual shot to get it to look
as real as it does in the film
[Music]
so the other creature we gotta talk
about is the great protector when you
saw the great protector in the script
what went through your mind
i thought to myself i can't believe i'm
gonna be making a movie about a dragon
that's so cool this was an interesting
character in many ways because it wasn't
the normal traditional western dragon it
doesn't have wings it doesn't breathe
fire you'll notice in the film that
whenever you see this particular
character she is always moving she's
always slithering and sliding along
through the air we looked at eels and
water snakes of how they traveled
through water and used a lot of that as
reference for our movement so once you
understand the movement what kind of
prep goes into a scene where you know
the actors are going to be interacting
with this creature one of the great
things about
this particular dragon is we have
characters actually riding it because of
that we had to build a what we would
call a buck
and we went to our visual effects
company who was working on the dragon we
then asked them to create a simplified
version of just the head portion
particularly in a small portion of the
body that people were able to hold onto
and sit on and sort of interact with so
putting this whole piece onto a gimbal
so that it rotates and spins and moves
and tilts and everything and then we
photograph our actors sitting on this
thing with wind and sometimes rain to
imply that they were going through water
and then we added big camera moves
trying to emulate the sense that they
were flying it's very very challenging
to try and make that stuff look real but
i think you know it's it's incredibly
fun challenge
so once you have that footage what kind
of processes does it need to go through
with vfx the challenge particularly once
we'd actually got this photography was
then putting that into our world of
tallow which is where the dragon exists
in this sort of mythical place we also
have to figure out where the camera is
in relation to the body of the dragon
and then tracking the dragon so the
dragon now has a cg dragon and then on
top of the real world camera that we
have we then add additional camera
movements and we then start building our
cg world around that um and start
putting in all other action beats
now looking back at this incredible film
and all of the characters you got to
help create what was your favorite part
of working on this project i've been
very fortunate in my career working with
marvel to do several origins films and
they're always really fun there's an
overall aesthetic to the film that leans
into some aspects of mcu sort of history
but also the great thing about an origin
story is you get to develop your own
look and i'm looking forward to seeing
what an audience thinks of the film
thank you so much chris and of course
everyone go see marvel studios shangqi
and the legend of the 10 rings in
theaters now
[Music]
you